So I've drawn an arbitrary
triangle over here
that we will assume is not
an equilateral triangle.
And let's draw some of
the interesting properties
of this triangle.
So, let's first start with
the perpendicular bisectors.
So let's say this is the
midpoint of this side
right over here.
So-- draw a little bit closer
to the midpoint-- looks
like right about there.
So this length is equal to
this length right over here.
And so let me draw a
perpendicular bisector.
So perpendicular bisector
would look something
like that for that side.
Now let me do it on this side.
So just trying to
eyeball it, this
looks roughly like the midpoint.
So this length is going to be
equal to this length, and then
once again, let me draw
a perpendicular bisector,
so it's going to go
at a 90 degree angle.
I can draw a straighter
line than that.
So that looks pretty good.
And it is perpendicular.
And then you can imagine I
will do it with this side,
with side AB.
That looks like the midpoint.
This length is going to
be equal to that length
right over there.
And then if we draw a
perpendicular-- my best attempt
to draw this-- it looks
something like that.
And we've already learned
that these three lines will
definitely intersect in a unique
point right over there, which
we call the circumcenter.
So let me write it.
So this right over there
is our circumcenter.
This is nothing new.
Now let's draw the medians.
So, the medians go from
each of the vertices
to the midpoint of
the opposite side.
So let me draw.
So this is a median, this is
a median, this is a median,
and then this is-- and all
the errors in my drawing
will start to become
apparent, now that I'm
trying to do multiple
things with it.
But we know all of the medians
intersect at the centroid.
So this right over
here is the centroid.
Now let's draw the
altitudes of this triangle.
So let's draw the altitude.
So I'm going to drop a
perpendicular right over here.
This is one altitude.
I will draw another altitude.
So remember, it's going
to go down like this.
Draw another altitude that
looks something like that.
And then I can draw another
altitude from this side,
and we know it's going to
intersect at this unique point
right over here.
So I'll try to draw
it as neatly as I can.
And this is going
to be perpendicular,
although the way I've drawn
it, it doesn't necessarily
look that way.
And we know that this
thing right over here
is called an orthocenter.
Now the whole reason
why I'm doing this,
and this is frankly kind
of a mind-boggling idea.
It's neat enough that each
of these points even exists,
that three altitudes will
intersect in one point,
that the three medians
and they have all
these neat properties,
and that the three
perpendicular bisectors
intersect in one point.
That by itself is neat enough.
But what's really neat--
and it's maybe not
completely apparent by the
way I drew it, because I just
drew it free hand-- is that
these three points will
definitely be on the same line.
If this was an
equilateral triangle,
they would actually
be the same point.
But for any other triangle
there'll be different points,
and they will be
on the same line.
Which is just kind of crazy,
because obviously two points
define a line, but three
points being on the same line
is kind of a-- it seems
like a very unlikely thing,
if you were to just guess it.
And I'm going to try to
draw it as best as I can.
If you were to draw this
with a straight edge ruler,
it would come out a lot cleaner.
But all three points
sit on this unique line
that, it seems something
special or magical about it.
And because it's something
special or magical,
there's one famous
mathematician who
tends to get all of the most
special and mathematical things
named after him, because
he's the guy who's
really explored these things.
And we call this the Euler line.
And I say that Leonhard
Euler-- that looks like ENTER.
I say that he gets all
of the cool and magical
mystical things named after
him, because he's also
responsible for
Euler's identity, which
is e to the i pi is
equal to negative 1.
And we proved this in
the calculus playlist,
and if none of this makes any
sense to you, don't worry.
We're only in
geometry right now.
But he gets to
have all the-- This
is a magical thing because e
comes out of compound interest,
and growth and decay,
exponential growth and decay.
i squared is negative
1-- seems a very bizarre
imaginary number.
Pi is a ratio of
the circumference
of a circle to its diameter.
And negative 1 is,
well, negative 1.
And so Euler showed that
there's a lot of reason
to believe that these
four numbers that
come from all of these different
weird realities of the world
are connected in
this very tight way.
And he also showed that
these special points
are all on the same
line, which tells us
something kind of crazy and
mystical about our reality.
And if that is not
enough for you,
if you were to take the
midpoint on the Euler
line between the orthocenter--
I'm not going to prove it here,
I'm just going to give you a
little bit of a tidbit of it.
If you take the midpoint
between the orthocenter
and the circumcenter--
so let's take this.
So I'm going to try
to look at it roughly.
So it looks like it's
right about there.
So this length is going
to be equal to this length
right over here.
This point that sits
on the Euler line
is going to be the center
of something called
the nine-point circle,
which intersects
this triangle at nine points.
And we'll see this kind of
nine interesting points.
So let me label that as well.
So it's cool enough that
these three special points are
on the Euler line, but there's
actually four special points.
And actually, there's
a few more than that
are kind of interesting.
So that orange point
right over there
is the center of the
nine-point circle.
And maybe I'll do another video,
another video just on that.
So anyway, hopefully you found
that kind of interesting.